> IN OUR WORLD LEAD, A GROWING
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AND MAKING
MEXICO CITY THEIR NEW HOME.
THE REASON, WELL REMOTE WORK AND
CHEAPER LIVING COSTS.
BUT LOCAL RESIDENTS IN MEXICO
CITY SAY AMERICANS ARE BRINGING
IN GENTRIFICATION AND DRIVING UP
EVERY DAY COSTS FOR MEXICANS.
CNN'S DAVID CULVER TAKES A LOOK
AT THE CAUSE AND EFFECT OF
AMERICANS SETTLING IN MEXICO
CITY.
>> Reporter: LOOK PAST THE
CHARMING CAFES AND FLASHING
APARTMENTS AND YOU'LL SEE THIS
CAPITAL CITY FOR WHAT IT IS
BECOMING.
A REFUGE MORE MIGRANTS.
>> I GREW UP IN L.A.
>> ATLANTA.
>> AMERICANS LEAVING PRICEY U.S.
CITIES HEADING SOUTH TO WORK
FROM HOME, IN MEXICO CITY.
>> IT IS STARTING TO FEEL LIKE
HOME.
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS ALREADY.
>> Reporter: BORN AND RAISED IN
THE UNITED STATES, ERIC HARDLY
SPEAKS SPANISH AND IS NOT HERE
TO REDISCOVER HIS MEXICAN ROOTS
SO MUCH AS TO SAVE MONEY.
>> MY APARTMENT WAS POSSIBLY
$2,500.
>> FOR A ONE BEDROOM.
>> FOR A STUDIO.
>> HERE I HAVE A ONE BEDROOM AND
I PAY $800 A MONTH.
>> Reporter: 1.6 MILLION U.S.
CITIZENS LIVE IN MEXICO BUT THEY
DON'T SAY HOW MANY ARE THERE ON
TOURIS
TOURIST VISAS.
BUT THEY RECORDED MORE THAN
5.3 MILLION AMERICAN TOURISTS
FLYING IN DURING THE FIRST FIVE
MONTHS OF THIS YEAR.
NEARLY A MILLION MORE THAN THAT
SAME PERIOD IN 2019.
PRE-PANDEMIC.
BUT HE'S AMONG THE UNRECORDED
AND UNDENIABLY PRESENT DIGITAL
NOMADS, HERE AS TOURISTS MOST
WORKING REMOTELY FOR U.S.
COMPANIES STILL GETTING PAID IN
U.S. DOLLARS, ALLOWING FOR A FAR
MORE AFFORDABLE LIFE IN MEXICO.
>> I THINK THERE WAS A SENSE OF
WE WANT PEOPLE TO COME HERE TO
STIMULATE THE ECONOMY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
BUT I KNOW THAT RECENTLY THERE
HAS BEEN COMPLAINTS FROM LOCALS
ABOUT THE EFFECT THAT EX PATS
LIVING HERE HAS HAD ON THEIR OWN
LIFESTYLES.
>> Reporter: SANDRA ORTIZ IS ONE
OF THEM.
THE PRICES ARE GOING UP HIGH.
SHE SAID IT IS DIFFICULT BECAUSE
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE COME AND
THEY HAVE A BUNCH OF MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO SPEND ON APARTMENTS AND
RENT.
>> FOR MORE THAN 50 YEARS ORTIZ
AND HER SIBLINGS RAN A
RESTAURANT POPULAR WITH LOCALS
ON A PRIME CORNER IN THE
DESIRABLE NEIGHBORHOOD, BUT AS
PRICES CLIMBED, ORTIZ SAID IT
BECAME UNAFFORDABLE FOR THE
FAMILY.
AND IN FEBRUARY, SHE SAID THEY
WERE EVICTED.
ALL THEIR BELONGINGS PILED ON TO
THE SIDEWALK.
>> YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES TO GET
EVERYTHING OUT AND MOVE IT OUT
OF THE --
>> Reporter: SO WHERE DO THE
LOCALS GO?
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO BE
ASKING OURSELVES, FERNANDO TELLS
ME.
THE PANDEMIC COUPLED WITH GLOBAL
INFLATION HAVE MADE MATTERS
WORSE LEAVING LOCALS IN FEAR OF
A CULTURE CLASH.
THIS IS PART OF THE PROBLEM, HE
SAID.
THE EX PATS MOVE HERE BECAUSE IT
IS CHEAP, NOT BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO TRULY IMMERSE IN THE LOCAL
CULTURE.
FAMILIES LIKE THE ORTIZ'S FEEL
THEY'RE GETTING PUSHED OUT.
SANDRA AND TWO OF HER SIBLINGS
NOW WORKING AT ANOTHER
RESTAURANT, NO LONGER THE
OWNERS.
THE THOUGHT OF VISITING THEIR
OLD RESTAURANT -- TOO PAINFUL.
WE WENT BY, RENOVATIONS ARE
ALREADY UNDERWAY.
HIGH END APARTMENTS COMING SOON.
AND JAKE FOR FOLKS LOOKING AT
THIS REPORT AND SAY WELL PERHAPS
I'LL TAKE MY WORK FROM HOME TO
MEXICO CITY, IT DOES SEEM LIKE
THERE IS AN UNOFFICIAL CRACKDOWN
UNDERWAY RIGHT NOW ON PART OF
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
WE'RE HEARING FROM SOME U.S.
TRAVELLERS WHO SAY AS SOON AS
THEY ARRIVE, MEXICAN OFFICIALS
AT THE BORDER ARE LIMITING THEIR
STAY TO SOME AS FEW AS JUST TEN
DAYS.
SAYING THEY NEED TO LEAVE AFTER
BEING IN THE COUNTRY FOR TEN
DAYS.
NOW AGAIN, THIS IS UNOFFICIAL.
SO WE'VE ASKED THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT ABOUT THIS.
THEY SAY AS OF NOW THEIR CURRENT
FOLLOWSY STILL STANDS AND THERE
IS NO CHANGE BUT THERE IS SOME
EFFORT TO TRY TO CURB THIS ABIT.
IT IS A DELICATE DANCE FOR SOME
OFFICIALS BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
CRACK DOWN AND TRY TO LIMIT
PEOPLE STAYING TOO LONG BUT ON
THE OTHER, THEY DON'T WANT TO
DISSUADE U.S. TOURISM WHICH
BRINGS IN BILLIONS OF DOLLARS